verifying into implants overnight any  thoughts very much for the people of  France and nice and absolutely appalling  instinct I think there'll be ministerial  meetings later on today to discuss the  implications for this country if any  girl I don't I don't care if I know any  read across all or informations about  the UK clearly this represents a  continuing threat because as a terrorist  incident appear to be this represents a  continuing threat to us in the whole of  of Europe and we must reach it together  but we know the fair many persons  involved well the only information that  I that I have is that there is one UK  national who's who's injured but I  deserve it and you'll be speaking to  your counterparts in class today